son visage porte encore les traces de
son agression de dimanche huguette a le
nez cassé de multiples hématomes mais
elle tient bon son agresseur elle ne lui
a pas rendu la tâche facile nous
explique-t-elle trois jours après les
faits la conductrice de taxi tourangelle
revient sur les deux heures qu'elle a
passées dans le coffre de son véhicule
professionnel et sur le pire qu'elle a
évidemment envisager
[Musique]
mon papa n'est plus parmi nous mais je
pense à lui en disant surtout battu me
quitte pas et je pense à mes proches mon
conjoint mes nièces ma maman âgée parce
que j'ai une maman âgée et je me dis
mais faut pas qu'elle apprenne ce à quoi
parce qu'elles savent à la rendre malade
quand je vais aux autres alors je veux
bien qu'elle voit comme ça en jeu ah oui
non mais je pensais plus aux autres qu'à
moi en fait et je dis mais non mais il
faut que je me débrouille je vais y
arriver de toute façon je vais y arriver
[Musique]
j'étais sûr de griller parce que c'est
mon ravisseur n'avait avait pu changer
la roue de ma voiture on partait pour
quelle destination
aucune idée dans le milieu des bois
certainement et avec ce qu'il y avait à
l'intérieur de la voiture je n'étais pas
là pour rester en vie quand la police
m'a montré les photos avec trois bidons
d'essence d'essence de 2 litres mis
derrière mon dossier mon siège ouais le
conductrice là je me suis dit non là ce
qui m'attendait c'était d'être grillé
[Musique]
je vais avoir mon ange gardien avec moi
je pense mais oui j'ai eu beaucoup de
chance et je crois que je dois beaucoup
de choses à mon collègue de bois ça
c'est sûr est ce que vous l'avez
rencontré votre je n'ai pas encore
rencontré gelé au téléphone je les
téléphones mais il sait que je veux le
voir parce que non pour moi c'est
important trophy et puis c'est grâce à
lui que je suis encore en vie huguette
s'est vu prescrire 45 jours d'itt et et
elle n'est pas sûre de vouloir reprendre
le volant du véhicule dans lequel elle
s'est retrouvée prisonnière et mais elle
compte bien rapidement retourner au
travail son agresseur en état de
récidive sera jugé par le tribunal de
blois il encourt la réclusion criminelle
à perpétuité